hi in this video I'm going to talk about
glycogenesis let's break the term glyco
means glycogen here and Genesis means
formation so basically these means
glycogen formation so when we take a
meal full of carbohydrate it's get
broken down into glucose and that
glucose have to be stored somewhere
inside the body as a energy reserve the
glucose is usually stored in in the
liver or in the muscles and the process
by which glucose get converted into the
glycogen and that means a storable form
is called glycogenesis so let's see step
by step how these glycogenesis process
occurs so here we have glucose glucose
is our substrate for glycogenesis so
glucose would be converted firstly to
glucose 6-phosphate Lucas would be
converted to glucose 6-phosphate
and these is a phosphorylation reaction
and this reaction would be catalyzed by
hexa kinase hexokinase enzyme which is a
very important enzyme in this pathway
next what would happen glucose
6-phosphate now it would be converted
into glucose 1-phosphate and it's
isomerization reaction and this reaction
is catalyzed by phosphoglucomutase
this reaction is catalyzed by
phosphoglucomutase so now if we talk
about the structure of the glucose
glucose um what looks like this so this
is the basic structure of glucose so
here is the one two three four five and
sixth carbon so in the sixth carbon what
would happen in the next step in glucose
would be phosphorylated in its sixth
carbon and it will form glucose
6-phosphate
so let's see so here in the sixth carbon
of the glucose here we would attach a
phosphate group by these hexokinase
enzyme and this is called glucose
6-phosphate and now what happens glucose
6-phosphate would be converted into
glucose 1-phosphate and these glucose
1-phosphate is actually a isomer of
these glucose 6-phosphate
I say after getting converted into
glucose 1-phosphate
it would be converted into UDP glucose
and the enzyme the reaction is catalyzed
by UDP glucose phosphor is this is
catalyzed by UDP glucose phosphorylase
so now it would be converted into UDP
glucose and UDP glucose would look like
somewhat
so this is the structure of udp-glucose
when are you reading moiety is attached
and udp-glucose is very important for
addition into our preformed glycogen or
polymer so we have a preformed glycogen
polymer we would denote it as n and now
it would attach with udp-glucose and
ultimately it would form glycogen and it
would increase the chain by one or a
seed you know so this would be no final
reaction so now if we talk about how
this glycogen preformed glycogen polymer
appears so you should talking about a
protein named as glycogen E and this
glycogenin protein is actually a dimer
so these glycogenin protein has two
subunits of unit a and subunit B and at
the terminal position it has a tyrosine
group with this tyrosine group with this
tyrosine group some glucose molecules
some glucose moieties actually attached
and this glucose moieties are with these
glucose moieties farther attachment of
other glucose moieties takes place
I mean UDP glucose directly attached to
these moieties and along it the chain
that is how it occurs so the chain gets
along it continuously and this is the
basic reaction scheme so next we would
talk little about the regulation you
would talk about regulation
regulation so one enzyme I want you to
remember is in this step this step is
catalyzed from glycogen plus udp-glucose
and it forming a glycogen n plus one
residue this and this step is actually
catalyzed by one very important enzyme
which is a rate limiting enzyme for this
glycogenesis step
this is glycogen synthase
this is glycogen synthase and this
enzyme is very important because it is
the rate-limiting enzyme so this is the
rate-limiting enzyme in this pathway so
this rate limiting enzyme could get
allosteric modification so that we would
see how this rate limiting enzyme get
allosteric modification so glycogen
synthase generally have two forms one is
it has like a gene
synthase in a forum glycogen synthase in
a forum and glycogen synthase in a form
is not phosphorylated and it is acting
for another firm is the glycogen
synthase in a B form and glycogen
synthase in B form is inactive because
it is the phosphorylated version of the
enzyme and in a phosphorylated State
these is inactive so it is
phosphorylated as you can see and this
is not phosphorylated and this is active
State so the switching between these
active conformation and inactive
conformation would ultimately regulate
this pathway so let's see how this
pathway take place so so now what
happens so from inactive state to active
state switching is catalyzed by for a
phosphatase enzyme phosphatase enzyme
phosphoprotein phosphatase and this
enzyme is regulated by other hormones
such as insulin so what happens insulin
actually triggers the activity of
phosphoprotein phosphatase and thus
inactive form of glycogen synthase get
active and ultimately the glycogenesis
reaction take place glucose get
converted into glycogen but glucagon and
epinephrine on the other side allosteric
Lee or hinders these phosphoprotein
phosphatase glucose 6-phosphate also
negatively regulate phosphoprotein
phosphatase and on the other side the
conversion of active form into inactive
form is triggered by GSK glycogen
synthase kinase so when glycogen
synthase kinase is active what will
happen glycogen synthesis would become
phosphorylated
ultimately glycogen synthesis would be
inactive so insulin actually inhibits
this glycogen synthase kindness
so insulin inhibits luggage ins in this
kindness so the active form doesn't get
converted into an active form so in
presence of insulin the glycogen
synthase a form that means the active
form takes part in the reaction and it
ultimately converts glucose into
glycogen so that blood glucose level
could be lowered and the glucose could
be stored inside our liver for future
purposes hope you enjoyed the video
please like and subscribe